it was a cold case for more than two
decades until DNA was a match while the
killer finally heads to prison the
victim's family says justice didn't have
to be delayed we thank you for joining
us here at six o'clock I'm Denise Valdez
and I'm Brian Loftus it is a story 8
news now investigator Vanessa Murphy has
been following she has the very latest
on concerns from the victim's loved ones
I think it's bull Marie Coker and her
family waited more than two decades for
her sister's killer to be found Nadia
Iverson was left for dead in downtown
Las Vegas in 1997. on Tuesday Arthur
Sewell a former police officer was
sentenced to 6 to 15 years for voluntary
manslaughter with use of a deadly weapon
he could be released from prison in less
than two years since he's receiving
credit for time already served in jail
he had 20 years of his life to live a
secret life of who he really wasn't
Sewell had resigned from Metro just
months before Iverson's killing after he
was caught forcing women to perform sex
acts an investigation revealed Iverson
may have been sexually assaulted in
addition to being shot then in 2018
after the state of Nevada addressed a
backlog of rape kits Sewell was arrested
police say his DNA was a match Iverson's
family says they were told the delay a
was due to funding we're in Nevada
it doesn't add up how can you not have
the money
for these families for this culture for
the victim and then
my remorseful most definitely a judge
tossed out sewell's confession ruling
detectives here violated his Miranda
rights by continuing to question him
without an attorney he still has a right
to have his rights read and because that
wasn't done they failed our family
Iverson's loved ones say they are
pleased with how the Clark County
District Attorney's Office handled the
case and they believe prosecutors hands
were tied since that confession was
tossed out and that's why the plea deal
was on the table today I'm here to face
for killer to speak my pain Sewell
offering no apology at the sentencing
Iverson's loved ones say they'll attend
his parole hearings to make sure he
serves the full 15-year term Vanessa
Murphy 8 News Now
we can also tell you tonight that
Vanessa reached out to Metropolis to
find out how more about the detectives
involved in the Attorney General's
office to get an update on whether there
is currently any backlog of rape kits
and both agencies say they're working to
get that information according to the
AG's office website though there was a
backlog of more than 7 800 rape kits
which were processed resulting in 64
arrests it is unclear how recently that
was updated though